begin this hour with a new royal baby
the duke and duchess of sussex as prince
harry and meghan markle announced
yesterday
that their long-awaited daughter was
born on friday they've named her lilybet
diana mountbatten windsor
lily for short that's what they're going
to call her lily batter is an old family
nickname for queen elizabeth
her great-grandmother and diana of
course is for harry's mother princess
diana
lily was born at a hospital in santa
barbara california she weighed in at
seven pounds 11 ounces
buckingham palace congratulated harry
and megan saying
that the royals are delighted with the
news prince william and his wife kate
also congratulated them on twitter now
you may remember that harry and megan
first told oprah
that they were having a girl back in a
cbs interview in march
cbs news royal contributor tina brown is
with us she's the author of the diana
chronicles and has covered the royal
family extensively
good morning to you tina i was so
excited
good morning tina's my partner in crime
and all things royals we were there for
the wedding that day
i was so excited when i heard the news
over the weekend over the weekend that
baby lily had arrived
and i think the the name that they've
given in tribute to the queen and a
tribute to diana
is a very nice touch what did you think
of it when you heard
well it's a it's an enchanting name
isn't it let's face it
or it's an enchanting name i mean
amongst the royal
sort of older gen there was a few raised
eyebrows i'm told about
using the queen's very intimate nickname
that only
her mother her sister and her husband
were allowed to use
and tina wait stop stop for a second on
that because i heard that and i went oh
please
now you're criticized because you're
paying tribute to the queen
and now they get criticized for that i
don't think it's silly i don't think
anyone's criticizing i mean
basically people are overjoyed about
this baby because
uh you know the queen herself just loves
having all of these grandchildren you
know this this lily is her
11th and i'm sure she's touched and
amused and thrilled
that the baby has her nickname uh you
know and i also feel it's a great
softening
uh mechanism for the family right now
which has had a lot of friction and a
lot of wounds uh there's nothing more
uniting than the advent of a new child
and uh this is going to be i think a
helpful emollient
there's no doubt that i mean the queen
just loves having all these children are
running around she's actually got
a very maternal streak now i mean in her
early days she found it very difficult
to be the kind of mother she wanted to
be with everything that was on her back
but actually as a grandmother and a
great grandmother
she has truly got into that role and
loves it so
i think she hopes that she'll see lilly
i'm sure she does i'm told
yeah she's very archie so everybody
wants to see lily
everybody wants to see ladies let's hope
that she takes they both
arrive in london in a happy mood
bringing both children everyone would be
thrilled i think i
know i was so i was i was just
disappointed to hear that there were any
raised eyebrows about the baby's name
but moving on
baby lily makes history because she's
the first senior royal to be born here
in this country
so what does this mean in terms of
succession
actually won't change it won't change uh
lily's
posse uh position in the line of
succession she's number eight
now in the last obsession and it doesn't
matter where she's born
the being of she have a title will will
have she yes she will have a title
when uh the queen dies and charles
becomes king
she can use the title uh princess lily
if she wishes
uh she will be a princess as will
actually be a prince that was always
going to be true
when the queen died and archie and
charles became king
she could also choose to be just plain
lily
mountbatten windsor or even lily sussex
if she prepares she also could use that
name if she wish
whatever happens if she's princess lily
she is going to be the coolest girl in
america
that's true it's anthony it's been three
months since uh harry and megan's
interview with
oprah we heard roy anika say earlier in
this broadcast that
most of the fences have not been mended
since that
um you said you think this will
obviously soften folks up but how much
damage
is there from what we know
i think there's a lot of damage actually
but uh
i do know that the family are still very
much hoping
to be able to mend the fence with harry
particularly william
uh whose bro you know he is and
who has had such incredible bonds with
his
brother so there's a hope a a desire
even if it's just a crack to open that
door they want to keep that door widely
opened
and i'm also told the queen has actually
been very worried about harry since
all of this began you know he's talked
very publicly about his mental health
problems and it's truly spoken to the
queen i mean she's very concerned about
harry's mental health and she's very
anxious
not to do anything uh for him that will
make him feel kind of pushed
out or prematurely sort of you know
we're closing the door she doesn't want
to close the door and his father doesn't
either actually because his father has
been i think probably the most wounded
by all of this
because inadequate though he may have
been at times he
also felt uh that he'd done his best as
a father
and i think was very taken aback by some
of the things that
uh that harry has said recently about
him well at the end of the day they are
still family you know we know
um diana's birthday is coming up july
1st she would have been 60.
there are big plans planned in the uk
for that so
it'll be a chance for the family to all
see each other i think it's very
exciting times for everybody thank you
tina thank you very much